تواجه مهنه المحاماه في السعوديه عده
تحديات منذ سنوات مضت وسط انتقادات من قبل
البعض حول اداء بعض المحامين في الكثير من
القضايا داخل السعوديه وجود المكاتب
الاجنبيه في المملكه هو شيء ايجابي يرفع
سوق المنافسه ويفتح مجال العمل للسعوديين
النقطه الثانيه ان
المكاتب السعوديه مؤهله غير مؤهله مؤهله
ومؤهله على مستوى عالي تعاون بين المكاتب
مكاتب المحاماه وفتح مكاتب محاماه اجنبيه
مهم جدا
ويعود ايجابا على سوق العمل
والتطور العدلي
الانتقادات طالت بعض الممارسات التي
يشهدها سلك المحاماه من توجه للوعظ
والوصايه والبعد عن ممارسه الدور الرئيس
للمهنه وهو الترافع وتوعيه المدعين بما
لهم وما عليهم فيما ذهب اخرون الى ان
حداثه التنظيم الفعلي لمهنه المحاماه في
السعوديه والذي اقر قبل واحد وعشرين عاما
فقط ساهمت في انتشار مثل تلك الممارسات حل
القضايا في الصلح او بالتسويات هذا معمول
لي في اكبر دول العالم مش في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
فمرور القضيه بمراحل التسويه وكثير من
القضايا بالذات في امريكا يعني اوروبا
قضيته حل خارج المحاكم بطريقه التسويه
بشكل كبير وهذا يعتبر على فكره من كفاءه
وشطاره المحامي مش مش تقليل من من عمله او
من كفاءته وزاره العدل السعوديه قررت
السماحه مؤخرا بالحصول على ترخيص بمزاوله
المهنه لمكاتب المحاماه الاجنبيه من خلال
تقديم طلب عبر بوابه الخدمات العدليه
الالكترونيه ناجز التابعه لوزاره العدل
المكاتب حقيقه الموجوده الان دخلت في
عمليه اعاده غربله كبيره جدا لواقعها
بعضها قرر الخروج بعضها قرر التطوير
وبعضها قرر مواءمه واقعه مع القواعد
الجديده الحقيقه سيكون له انعكاس كبير جدا
ايجابي على واقع العمل القانوني وجذب
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وتشير احصاءات رسميه الى زياده
ملحوظه في اعداد المنتسبين لمهنه المحاماه
من السعوديين حيث وصل عدد المحامين المرخص
لهم اكثر من 14 الف محامي منهم
11,355 محاميا
2,833 محاميه جميعهم يمثلون عددا من
التخصصات القانونيه من جده سعود الخلف
العربيه
استديوهاتنا من الرياض المحامي ماجد قارب
دكتور مجد حياك
تواجدك معنا خليني اسمع اول شيء التعليقك
ما زالت الانتقادات مستمره حول مهنه
المحاماه في السعوديه ما رايك في هذا
الكلام وفي اكثر من مجال بالمجمل حقيقه
نتفق معهم فيها اللي سبب بسيط جدا انه
نظام المحاماه منذ ان صدر من اكثر من 20
سنه تحدث عن فتره انتقاليه مدتها خمسه
سنوات لتعديل وتطوير النظام حتى يتمكن من
دفع المهم المهنه الى الامام وانتشالها من
السلبيات التي كانت تشوبها حتى الان حقيقه
لم تعدل اهم هذه التعديلات للفتره
الانتقاليه الا منذ شهور بسيطه جدا وهذا
ما يحسب لوزاره العدل
بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى مؤخرا
ولذلك تنظيم المحاماه تنظيم مهنه المحاماه
الذي صدر منذ ما يقارب 10 سنوات لم يتمكن
من انتشال المهنه من العشوائي ان صح
التعبير الى ما نتطلع اليه في اطار الرؤيه
وما تستحق المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
قضاء منسوب الى الشريعه الاسلاميه والشارع
الاسلامي الحنيف ان تكون في مستوى مهني
رائع جدا بالرغم من كون انه التنظيم ينص
انه الهدف الاساسي له هو تمكين المحامين
من الالمام بمهنيه مهنه المحاماه والالمام
بها والعمل على وفق اسسها ولكن وجود
النظام الذي لم يعدل الا منذ شهور بسيطه
ليش لم يعدل لمده شهور يعني
ولا يمكن ان نقول انه حتى التجربه حديثه
يعني 21 سنه مش فتره قصيره
من اهم عيوب النظام القديم انه كان يسمح
لكل من يستطيع ان يحصل على وكاله بالترافع
من الام والغير متعلم والمحامي والمهندس
والطبيب ورجل الشارع العادي واي واحد عنده
وكاله يستطيع ان يترفع هذا منع وبالتالي
الاساس هو انعكاس ذلك تنظيم على
الثقافه الحقوقيه للمجتمع حتى يستطيع ان
يعلم ان كلمه محكمه تعني فقط قاضي ومحامي
وليس اي واحد يروح زي دعوه وكيله بخلافه
التعديل التنظيمي العام لمهنه المحاماه
اليوم يستطيع ان يحقق اهدافه بعد التعديل
الذي حصل على نظام المحاماه يضاف الى ذلك
حقيقه صدور وثيقتين مهمه جدا اكثر من
رائعه ستدفع المهنه تجاه ما نحن نعيش
اليوم من تطور في جميع قطاعات ومناحي
الدوله وهي لائحه قواعد سلوك المحامين
وهذه ستضع مبادئ اخلاقيه قبل ان تكون
مهنيه على اصحاب المكاتب والمحامين
المرخصين حتى يتمكنوا من اداء مهمتهم بشكل
احترافي ومهني سليم وستؤدي الى تعريفهم
بمعنى كلمه المهنيه لانها ليست مجرد رخصه
ليس كل من حصل على الرخصه مهني بقدر ما
انه يتطلب ان يتحول المرخص الى مهنيه
كامله ليست فقط في ممارسه امام القضاء
ستنعكس ايضا على الثقافه الحقيقيه
ما تقوم به الان وزاره العدل حقيقه في
الاسابيع والشهور الاخيره رائع جدا كيف
اهمها من يطلع على لائحه الترخيص في مكاتب
المحاماه الاجنبيه يجد كثير من المفردات
المهنيه فيها ستفرض على مكاتب المحاماه
الاجنبيه الى توطين مهنه الاستشارات
والمحاماه بشكل عالي الكعب ان صح التعبير
يعني بالتشبيه الرياضي هنكون مستخدمين
لكريستيانو رونالدو في المحاماه بهذه
الطريقه الرائعه وبالتالي هذا الرفع من
حجم الاعمال التي تؤديها مكاتب المحاماه
الاجنبيه في المملكه ستؤدي لهم بالضروره
اجبارا الى تدريب وتاهيل المحامين
السعوديين وبالتالي سيكون هناك تنافس مهني
على ارض الواقع بعيدا عن كونها المكاتب
الاجنبيه كانت نحصل على الاعمال وتؤديها
في خارج المملكه وبالتالي سيكون عندنا
ايلا ترسيخ وتوطين وتثبيت كثير من مبادئ
وقيم التعليم والتدريب للمحامين وبالتالي
سنرى قريبا جدا اجيال سعوديه قويه جدا
متمكنه من المستوى العالي لمهنه المحاماه
وايضا
تفضل ايضا ستؤدي الى
التعديلات الجديده في المنظومه القضائيه
بشكل عام التي بدات ترسخ لمبدا العداله
الوقائيه والدور الكبير والخطير والغير
مسبوق لمحاكم التنفيذ الى تفعيل ما يسمى
العداله الوقائيه وهذه ستعزز مكانه الدور
الاستشاري للمحامي ومكاتب المحاماه على
حساب الثقافه الحقوقيه الضعيفه للمجتمع
السعودي بشكل عام بشكل عام وايضا مجتمع
الاعمال انه المحامي فقط مرتبط بالقضيه
والمحكمه بينما في العالم كله الشق
الاستشاري حقيقه 90% من حجم اعمال كبرى
مكاتب المحاماه العالميه ولذلك احنا
مركزين في العشره في الميه وهو دور ثانوي
اذا مقورن بقوه وحجم اعمال مكاتب المحاماه
الكبيره التي يجب ان يتوجه اليها المحامي
السعودي ومجتمع الاعمال السعودي انت شايف
انه هذه اللوائح الجديده يعني
حتقلص او حتى تقضي على حاله الفوضى
والعشوائيه الموجوده يعني كم فتره زمنيه
يمكن نقول بانه هذه اللوائح كفيله في حال
وجدت المتابعه والمراقبه ان تقضي على هذه
الحاله ان طبقت بما يجب ان تطبق عليه نعم
انا اعتقد انه في خلال ثلاثه الى خمسه
سنوات سنكون في واقع احترافي عالي جدا
لانه اليوم الحياه الالكترونيه التي بكره
مؤتمر العداله السعودي سيركز في الحديث
عنها مع قواعد السلوك المهني مع التعديل
الذي حصل على نظام المحاماه مع الاسلوب
اقل من كده يعني هذه مساله فيها ثقافه
تغيير الثقافات ما ياتي ما بين يوم وليله
الافكار الصوره الذهنيه يعني العالم
العربي كله متاثر بالافلام العربيه عن دور
المحامي اللي فيه كثير جدا من العشوائيه
والشطاره والفحل تعبير البلطجه كل هذه
الامور حقيقه عشان تسحبها من دهنيه
المجتمع تحتاج الى تغيير من الوقت وتحتاج
الى وقت مهم جدا واعتقد انه يعني هيئه
المحامين مشكوره في في سبيلها انت ان
تتمكن من القيام باعمال يتلقاها مجتمع
الاعمال والمحامين بصوره ايجابيه افضل انا
بسالك عن نقطتين بشكل سريع دكتور ماجد
تفضل احداها الان هناك من يرى بانه يتم
انتحال صفه المحامي وخاصه في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي من خلال معرفاته واسماء
او غيرها من الامور ويقومون باعمال هي
اعمال مفترض ان تكون مكسوره على مهنه
المحاماه الاستشارات القانونيه في كتابه
المذكرات وغيرها هذه كيف ممكن يعني يتم
معالجتها والامر الاخر اللي ذكرته انت في
مقال لك ايضا انه انه هناك مجموعه من
التحديات القانونيه التي تعيق التنميه
وتحقيق مستهدفات الرؤيه الحديث عن انه
معظم الشركات العامه المدرجه في السوق
الماليه ليس بها ادارات قانونيه وكثير من
الجهات الحكوميه حتى من القطاع الخاص لم
تصل الى مثل هذه الثقافه على الرغم من من
انه مرتبطه تحقيق مستهدفتها هذه الرؤيه
بمعالجه مثل هذه الثغرات صحيح دكتور نظام
المحاماه بالرغم من انه كان يتحدث على انه
هناك عقوبه سجن وغرامه ماليه لمن ينتحل
صفه المحامي كان هناك ثغره قانونيه في
النظام تسمح لاي شخص انه ياخذ ثلاثه قضايا
بدون رقابه ولا تنسى انه انعدام الربط
الالكتروني بين المحاكم خلت الثلاثه تصير
3000 وبالتالي
اصبحت مهنه الترافع امام القضاء مهنه ليس
له مهنه وبالتالي هذا سبب شيوع وجود منتحل
صفه المحامين
والكل يتحدث عن علاقاته شبهات واشياء من
هذا القبيل في العهود السابقه وبالتالي
هذه الثقافه لا تستطيع ان تعيبها لانه كان
واقع عشوائي نعيشه اليوم هذا الانعدام
المهنيه والاحترافيه في العمل يجعل حتى
الجهات الحكوميه مع كل الاحترام لها بما
في ذلك الوزارات والهيئات لما تيجي تقيم
الادارات القانونيه اليوم في دراسه رائعه
جدا كاشفه للحقائق صدرت من معهد الاداره
العامه تحدثت عن مواقع الادارات القانونيه
في الاجهزه والوزارات الحكوميه كلها كانت
النتيجه حقيقيه احنا كمهنيين نعرفها تكاد
تكون صفريه من حيث المستوى والاداء ولانه
انعدام التاهيل اي واحد يكون في اي اداره
ويترقى عبر الزمن والتاريخ دون ان يكون في
هناك رقابه مهنيه احترافيه
لمستوى اداؤه معقول تجي تلاقي واحد
اي شيء تلاقيه مثلا في وزاره متخصصه معينه
تحتاج الى خبرات معينه في الاتحاد الدولي
المحامين عندنا
التخصصات القانونيه 55 تخصص قانوني
وبالتالي احنا نحتاج الى انه نفهم هذه
الثقافه ونفهم ان هناك تخصصات قانونيه وفي
داخل كل عنوان قانوني هناك تخصصات فرعيه
كثيره واضحه عشان كده بقول لك نحتاج الى
ثلاثه خمسه سنوات من العمل الجاد اللي
اليوم تقوده باحترافيه كبيره وزاره العدل
السعوديه شكرا لك يعطيك العافيه يا دكتور
ماجد قارون شكرا لك المحامي المعرف شكرا
مره اخرى شكرا